Using high explosives in a chaotic firefight can be... difficult.
(Casting)
Look whether you call it a Nitro Cell or a C4, there’s no arguing that it is one of the
best tools in a Defender’s arsenal.
And while sometimes things can go horribly wrong, it's still a great way to get highlight
reel kills on unsuspecting enemies.
(Casting)
Which is why this week on Top 10 we’re counting down the best nitro cell C4 plays in professional
Rainbow Six Siege.
It’s hard to stay calm and collected when you’re in a 1v1 clutch situation--especially
when you’re staring down matchpoint.
But that’s exactly what meepeY did in our opening play.
With excellent map knowledge and weapon usage, meepeY keeps his cool and throws a perfect
C4 to deny the plant and keep his team’s hopes alive.
(Casting)
You probably don’t want to be killing teammates with your C4s… or yourself for that matter.
But as our number 9 plays shows, sometimes things just work out and you win the round
anyway.
Here, Lunarmetal shows us that no sacrifice is too great in order to secure the W.
(Casting)
Sometimes, if you see it, well then it’s already too late.
Which is exactly what happened in our Number 8 play as Lipezord
accepted his fate, dying alongside his teammate with a well tossed Nitro Cell from
Cameraman.
(Casting)
At number 7 is one of the most calculated nitro cells you’ll ever see.
Okay, so… maybe it wasn’t on purpose… but Mark does show us that C4 can act as a
well placed trap that can catch a rushing enemy off guard.
With Siege’s destructible environment, players have the freedom to get creative and our number
six play has to be one of the craziest setups we’ve ever seen.
Here, FaZe’s Mav tosses his nitro cell from the attic, through the south wall and down
the floor for a cheeky kill on some poor soul in classroom.
(Casting)
Number 5 on the list takes place on a tied map of a tied series during a grand final.
Fabian (Faye-bian) refused to let EG take the lead and pulled through with a clutch
nitro cell on Canadian.
The Ash drops to the ground along with the defuser and with no time left on the clock,
Fabian hides from the remaining player, stealing the round from EG in heartbreaking fashion.
(Casting)
Never count BC out when he has a nitro cell in his pocket.
Coming in at the number 4 spot we have EG on the verge of elimination.
Fabian was looking to plant the defuser but found himself on the receiving end this time
around as BC’s nitro cell takes him out.
(Casting)
Our number three play sees Rogue able to plant the defuser under the cover of Glaz and a
smoke grenade.
With a 3v2 advantage, Rogue looked good to take the round but were not expecting the
C4 to come from nVk.
(Casting)
At the runner up spot, we have RaFaLe, who lands four kills with a Nitro Cell from below.
And to top it all off, he finishes the round with an ace.
(Casting)
You’re in a 1v4, you’ve just run out of bullets, you’ve got a sliver of health,
one plastic explosive and a dream.
Oh yeah, and you’re playing Kapkan.
"EDD primed."
For SK’s Nyx in our #1 spot, he turned that dream into reality as he lobbed a hail mary
nitro cell down the hatch into the server room, ending the round with a swift bang.
(Casting)
Well guys that’s all I got for you on Top 10 this week now  if you do wanna see more
Rainbow Six Siege content, like the video, subscribe to the channel, and let me know in the comments
so we can make it happen.
Thanks for watching. If you want more great content just like this, be sure to hit the subscribe button.